selling ugly produce to restaurants in
India yes
is that a YC thing it's a YC company yes
okay no dia and that's a company in
America and what's it called they know
that it's it's in India so it's farm
theory no oh there is also one here yeah
yeah there's a there's like a
farm-to-table box I think that's the
ugly produce thing in America for what
it's called it me too I just googled it
foods
yeah imperfect food so I'll give you the
stats on these guys so so they're doing
twenty-two thousand a month of em are
are they say forty percent profit
margins they say they're growing 65
percent week on week which doesn't mean
anything because it's YC but they're on
track to get to a million dollars a are
are the coming months what they're doing
is interesting they're taking farming is
huge in India so they're saying okay
there's tons of farming tons of produce
produced
there's tons that's not gonna get sold
because it looks ugly it's not good for
a consumer retail but we could buy that
stuff for cheap because it's just waste
otherwise we can sell it to restaurants
who don't care about the aesthetic look
of the you know they're not picking like
a consumer doesn't in the grocery store
where they pick a you know the
best-looking one out of a barrel the
wrestlers don't care they're chopping it
up processing it turning into food if
they can get lower food costs fantastic
and so they're looking at you know right
now at seven hundred twenty dollars a
month just for the restaurants in
Bangalore which is a part of India and
they're they believe it's a big marker
they claim a 500 million dollar market
just in Bangalore just through the
restaurants that are there sounds a
little high to me
but the the value prop makes sense the
restaurant saves about 30 percent by
buying ugly produce the farm gets some
revenue out of something that would
otherwise be no revenue and they take
their cut in the middle I like it what
do you think I like it now
but let me I'm always being like the
negative guy I like it but let me tell
you okay I'm a subscriber to imperfect
produce first of all it's not imperfect
like that this is a
stick of farm theory of them selling
like things that are ugly so what are
you saying they look normal you're
saying yeah it looks normal
I mean it doesn't look like it's a it's
a wonderful marketing scheme but is it's
it's so like it's just normal [__] right
right because I'm guessing you would not
sign up for something that just says
here's vegetable delivery
it's like saying there's a famous
copywriter named Joe Sugarman he wrote
this great ad for a new cast is it
called Cassio a Casio watch and he's
like we use space-age aluminum with
quartz movement and [__] every watch
has that same aluminum and quartz
movement is used in nearly every single
watch
he just explained it in a great way and
so this is a this is the same thing with
these guys and it's a stick that works
it's a real it's like it's like Guiness
Guiness putting a ping-pong ball in
their beer I don't know about that what
is that Guinness beer if you buy it in
the can there's a ping pong ball in it
because apparently that ping pong ball
has a little bit of night as if nitric
oxide some type of like gas in there
that keeps it super fizzy I see okay and
when they release that ball it like went
up big-time
I love it yeah so this is great
marketing I'm into it I don't know
anything about India so it's hard for me
to say that but I do know that I just
googled it
imperfect produce they have two hundred
thousand subscribers and wouldn't pay
per month roughly it's a weekly bill I
think I was paying $200 a month Wow
so incredible yeah big market so yeah
III think it would depend on how
talented these entrepreneurs are but you
definitely can build something
significantly significant here right
[Music]